good afternoon rory how can christy and
i help man
hey guys how are you guys doing doing
all right
hey so i had a quick question uh i'm
currently 18 years old i just moved out
of my parents house on monday
okay uh i'm i'm in school part-time at a
community college
and i i was just offered an internship
with amazon
and it's going to be 15 15 months it'll
be paid
and i'm cash in college i'm paying for
everything
and i was just wondering where i should
get started with the baby steps
oh man rory this is good now uh what
community college are you going to there
in raleigh
uh wake tech lake technical community
college absolutely yeah i know i know
all about wake tech man i was going to
go to a fayetteville tech
uh in fayetteville north carolina about
an hour and a half away from there so i
know exactly where you're going how much
is amazon paying you man for these
uh next 18 months uh it's gonna be
20 an hour uh 40 hours a week
some money brother that's what i'm
talking about okay any debt do you have
right now do you have any credit cards
uh no sir i'm completely debt free it's
a uh it's a robotic
internship they just look at the
warehouse here and i'm studying
mechatronics
so cool program
yeah that's awesome i love it i love it
well you know chrissy i think the very
first thing rory should do is really
just skip over baby step two
and really just start saving your three
to six months rory you're a young man
you just moved out on your own
and so what i want you to do is i want
you to sit down and get on every dollar
budget okay rory
what you're going to do is you're going
to list all of your income which is
going to be your amazon check
um if you're driving for uber eats if
you're doing anything extra i want you
to list all your income
then i want you to list all your
expenses so this is going to be you know
your rent this is going to be
you know if you have an iphone or
android phone any apps you're paying
for um you're a young man so i'm pretty
sure you're single so if you out dating
you need to have a line item for dating
okay
um so you got to get creative lists all
your expenses i know why your young
people out here laughing at me i know
that's real
i see y'all laughing at me uh but you
know you got to put everything on there
so you can have control over your money
that's the key thing that i really want
you to understand rory you're going to
start with baby step number three
and baby set number three is going to be
three to six months of your living
expenses okay
and you're gonna do that by getting on
an every dollar
budget and that's the first place where
i would say start
but the key thing is man once you get
that three to six months rory if you can
do that by the end of this year and
start investing next year you'll be 19
if you can start investing 15 of your
income
rory but before you turn 50 you're gonna
be a multi-millionaire
just by doing the bear basics uh so i
mean i love it i mean
here's the cool thing rory the fact that
you're asking this question
at 18 you gonna be okay like it
most 18 year olds are not asking this
question not calling the ramsay show
and not cash flowing their college you
are doing
awesome you're asking the right
questions you're already set up for
success the one
caution i would give you if you take
this internship which sounds like an
awesome opportunity you're about to have
some money
and when you got some money you know
what it does it wants to burn a hole in
your pocket because you're like oh i'm
living good i got all this money it
feels like so much and just like
anthony's telling you
don't lose focus of your goals and your
plan just because you got a little cash
in your pocket it'll be very tempting
to overspend that so just be aware of
that stick to your plan and you're going
to be just fine that's awesome
man listen here in those calls what's so
cool yeah i was not asking that question
at 18.
18. you know what i was doing at 18
mistakes i made some mistakes listen
here listen here man
i was like do i get another t-shirt for
that credit card where do i sign sign me
right on up yeah i had to pay for my
mistakes in my 20s
i'm thinking about t-shirts uh free
pizza
the ladies it's free money y'all no it's
not
no it's not no it's really not so rory
man take my hat's off to you thank you
so much for calling in you are a true
example of what
uh most 18 year olds what most young
people need to be doing is thinking
about their future
and so thank you for asking that
question